A knitter wanted to knit the body
of a kid's cardigan in one piece.
She planned to have a design along the
hem and she wanted to avoid side seams.
Here are the steps for combining the
back and front of a child's sweater.
Remember because of needle bed
limitations, this will only apply to
smaller size sweaters.
Create the basic shape of the
cardigan in Standard Garment Shaping.
Save your design and then open
it in Original Pattern Drafting.
Select the pieces and right click, drag,
and move them into the correct position.
Notice that there are three
points along each side seam.
To make things easier, let's use the
delete tool and remove that extra point
for now.
With one front active,
select the delete tool.
Choose the point you want to remove
from that active piece and delete it.
Turn off the tool, select the next
piece, which would be the back.
Turn on the tool.
Delete the points.
Turn off the tool, select the next
front piece, turn on the tool.
Delete the point.
Turn off the tool.
The feature we're going to
be using is >Piece and >Join.
Look closely, with the
pieces aligned this way.
If I joined them, I'll be adding width
to the body, which isn't what I want.
So I'll select the left piece and drag
it to align it with the back piece.
Notice that there's a red dotted line
indicating that they're in place.
The currently selected piece is light
gray, and the back piece is dark gray.
They are still two
separate pieces right now.
We'll click >Piece and >Join.
Notice that the cursor turns to a plus
sign, making it easier for you to select
the points.
Click on the top point of the selected
piece, and then click again to select the
point of the dark gray piece behind.
Scroll down to the
lower points and repeat.
Click and click.
Notice, now that both pieces are light
gray, so we've joined them, but you're not
finished.
To complete the join, you need to click
anywhere away from that new piece you
created.
Let's do it on the other side, right click
on that other front piece and drag it over
till it aligns with the back side seam.
Notice the red dotted line.
From the menu select >Piece and >Join.
Click, click on the top two points.
Click, click on the bottom, two points,
the piece is now, all the same color.
But notice these two symbols.
You still aren't quite done.
Don't forget to click away
from the piece to finish.
And we now have one piece fronts and backs
that we can cast on and get knitting.